he's CJ Anderson he's had quite a month
e'er the Rams running back week 16 167
yards versus the Cardinals week 17 132
yards against the Niners and then 123
yards in the divisional round versus the
Cowboys CJ Anderson Rams running back
joins us are you surprised at these
numbers at all CJ not really you know
all offseason and I put the time in try
to put myself in the best of this and
what Carolina I just think you know this
my sixth year in I'm seeing the game a
whole lot different but also helps that
I'm great teammates and I'm a wonderful
a lot you know playing extremely well
but as far as my ability and what I can
do
not too much surprised I was fine there
December 2 I guess when I was four to
help with insurance at one point and
then find a way to work myself all which
knee I think you have to do that what
every team Journal you always gotta find
a way to work yourself in a row and you
know now try and take advantage of
opportunity it you know because of my
experience and it's games that I've had
things I've definitely just try to put
myself in the position all right I'm
looking at this you sign with the
Panthers coming into 2018
then they waived you then you went on to
sign with the Raiders and then you were
released six days after that with the
franchise did you keep your jerseys that
you had with the Panthers in the Raiders
I did not know for sure
the Panthers jersey the number 20 was
special just a mother followed a brother
that was his number one he played and
obviously uh he couldn't play no more
because uh because they did the rated or
monitor news or anything so I was gonna
see if they were around
that but how much that hurt you're
really you know you you dream a plan for
the Raiders and then you get released
after six days no I was never released
when I was from Denver Carolina or
Oakland I was never released because of
talent you know Denver you know great
organization I'll respect him so much it
was cat space no as a writer back in his
league if you're not eat as I say no you
definitely don't think your works
dollars and that that makes sense that's
understandable you know they kept it a
kept it up front woman you know part of
ways and then you know Carolina you know
hopefully I'll get a chance to work puck
or hopefully I'll get a shot that worked
off in a role but you know what can you
say about Christian McCaffrey who might
be offered to Player of the Year this
year you know he had a second year in
the league and he's all prone talent
even element back hell of a person so
that his his emergence kept me up kept
me from being on the field you know
Oakland I get there you know getting
ready to play because of things that
they said with those interests of Martin
was healthy enough to play that we did a
duo lineman get hurt it makes sense you
got to protect a hundred million dollar
guys have to bring a guy uh practice
card and bring God back who they release
early in the year Hulu to play so just
to protect their car which is their
franchise so you know some weapons
around him next year so it makes this
little bit know what teams tell you
what's going on and some people in the
house for that world don't understand
that you know they just think I got
released because talent or you know
different things it was really timing
and circumstances of what the teams are
going to what's your official height and
weight I got I got a baby doing a in a
in April a donor due in April so I'm
kind of having that that man
so are you eating for two now are you in
your second trimester here everybody has
the jokes of hey I don't care as long as
you run that way
I would like I'm moving up like I'm
trying to put myself in the best
position obviously next year you know
along with all seasons concerns of the
work also say that you were doing oh you
know at one point every word Allah was
supposed to be we did you know after
being released from ochres dance company
here was over so I actually shut myself
down [ __ ] the year was over obviously
doesn't happen but I wasn't good enough
to play so that's why how would you
describe your style if somebody had not
seen you run against the Cowboys I roll
my eyes you know I'm not the fastest guy
in the world
decency decent quit this you know
something about kids all my career I
just try to try to be that one cut
downhill runner I wanted from Alex Kidd
specially come to eat learn from the
very coast like Gary Kubiak you know I
kind of understand this game but what's
going on and I just said well did you
know prior to the game and the Cowboys
you were gonna get that many carries you
got one of the best running backs it's
not the best running back in the league
you know if you want to play 98 percent
of the snaps when he got back he has
every right to do that I was just not to
miss a beat when he decided to take a
breather so you know just be prepared
for anything
you know like you're going to start
Lucky's gonna play cuz you are wanna
play awake I just took advantage of the
opportunity and the old while I play
really well I just tried to pick the
rice box you got a nickname that was
hang on to me so it's not these more
like one more shot but I'm thinking how
about the insurance policy we get Geico
to sponsor you and and you're known as
the insurance policy you know I promise
i turn it you know let people know you
know I'm still young in my career of
twenty seven at one point you know in
six seasons I have you know two
12-minute all-purpose seasons and I mean
I've held now I'm gonna this league so
it sound like uh you know been a backup
my whole career like that you know I've
been doing this role and I'm having fun
with it but uh like I said it's really
about how many first now it's possibly
get to trying to keep the tails moving
trying to do my part target more cosmic
there's access for bit ten after to wear
a championship where's your Super Bowl
ring it's a deposit box once you bring
it to practice nah you can't you can't
you know you can't I mean you know we
got a great challenge of this coming
weeks sitting down to the Superdome
flying across country to us against the
state of Louisiana and just trying to
find a way a way to knock off do breathe
and say no but try to put ourselves in a
lemon in a couple weeks
yeah but you just let everybody see it
you let him let the young guys see some
of the hardware not yet you know there's
different ways to deepen young guys
motivated you know I don't think this is
this is the time yet you know I think
there is a time you know what our Super
Bowl winner mark right before is
DeMarcus Ware put out the Lombardi
trophies how that one of the Broncos won
one of the two at the time that they
wanted them you know just kind of said
no it was in our way of this you know it
kind of silenced the mood I'm saying I'm
gonna do that this Sunday huh this
Saturday looks more before but there's a
third of time in a place when the Linda
let the young guys on the back of two of
the game it doesn't have to be past now
by myself or Keith you know who's who
had the opportunity or away does a great
job motivate us and I think we're all
motivated to uh to take care of business
this weekend he's known as bamm-bamm or
the insurance policy he's CJ Anderson of
the Rams good luck traveling to New
Orleans and uh congrats and good luck
with the baby in April CJ thank you all
right let's see J Anderson he ran for a
thousand yards last year and then Denver
released him and then you know he's not
playing this year you get released by
the Raiders and just sitting at home
chilling all of a sudden come on in he
rushes for a hundred yards next week
hundred yards then last week a hundred
yards and you got this is what New
Orleans has been very successful with
with their two-headed monster with
Ingram and Kamara and now the Rams have
that because kids currently can beat you
with power but he can also beat you with
speed and finesse CJ Anderson you
basically know what you're getting
he's coming in and that cement truck is
gonna hit you for more Dan Patrick show
to the audience channel 239 on DirecTV
or download the Dan Patrick show app
you